dos aviones casa derivaron el globo
chino que sobrevolaba a Estados Unidos
Desde hacía varios días según el
Ministerio de defensa su presencia
constituía una violación inaceptable de
la soberanía estadounidense por
atravesar zonas militares sensibles de
Norteamérica
el miércoles cuando fue informado sobre
el globo le ordené al Pentágono que lo
derribara Tan pronto como fuera posible
para no causar ningún daño en tierra
decidieron que la mejor manera era
hacerlo en el agua tuvieron éxito lo
derribaron y Quiero felicitar a los
pilotos que lo hicieron
[Música]
china lamentó lo sucedido y culpó a los
vientos de desviar lo que Beijing
considera que solo una aeronave civil al
espacio aéreo de Estados Unidos
china es un país responsable que siempre
ha acatado estrictamente las leyes
internacionales y no tiene intención de
violar el territorio y el espacio aéreo
de ningún país soberano las tensiones
entre Estados Unidos y China ya eran
elevadas y los avistamientos han
deteriorado aún más su relación el
secretario de estado Anthony ha decidido
Cancelar su viaje a Beijing previsto
para este domingo es un acto
irresponsable y la decisión de la
República popular china llevar a cabo
esta acción en vísperas de mi visita
prevista van detrimento de las
conversaciones que estábamos dispuestos
a mantener el gobierno chino ha negado
que hubiera alguna visita planeada y
declaró un accidente de fuerza mayor lo
ocurrido con el primer globo pero es que
un segundo ácido visto esta vez en
cielos latinoamericanos según el
pentágono el periódico local
costarricense la nación informó del
avistamiento de un globo ninguna
organización meteorológica nacional sea
responsabilizado de la nave